this is Richard sunx plane taking him to
West Coast America a brief pit stop in
Washington to refuel and then he's on
his way to San Diego an unusual first
destination for a UK prime minister to
go in America normally they head to
Washington but an unusual Summit because
tomorrow he and the U.S president and
the Prime Minister of Australia will all
stand up and talk about the threat posed
by China and what they're going to do
about it a big deal in the offing the
U.S planning to give second-hand
submarines to Australia while Britain
been builds new nuclear submarines to be
handed over in the decades to come an
important moment it's interesting to
hear the Prime Minister talk about the
acute threat particularly to Britain's
economy that the China now poses but
it's a risky time for him to be away
tomorrow in Parliament his government
will announce a tweak a change to the UK
strategy but will it involve Rishi doing
that reaching deep into government
Pockets to fund it sufficiently I
suspect there'll be some complaints that
it isn't all this at a time where a bank
has that funds important British tech
companies has gone bust and needs
rescuing there's the route with the BBC
Richard sunac says that he's very sad
it's taking place and then a budget on
Wednesday is this the right time to be
out of the country